welcome back to the 47th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
my name is alex and so far we've made
fifty four thousand
three hundred fifty eight dollars and
eighty six cents wow
that was good alex thank you so much for
coming on the podcast
this is a really exciting episode that
we've been waiting quite some time to do
uh let's just get this the cat out of
the bag right now
we picked the new assistant
congratulations alex
thank you a really exciting moment uh
how this came to be though was actually
kind of funny so
i found jack about a year it's been a
little bit over a year now
no it's been like over two years graham
really yes it's been over two years and
your appreciation
yeah you just whatever you've been
dating me for add like add two months
add two months gosh time flies okay so
anyway
so two years ago we've gotten really
busy here at the family
and we needed some extra help so i
talked to jack and we're like how do we
go about finding someone else to help us
out and
maybe you know help us with some editing
and like little errands here and there
so we think it's a good idea to go and
make a spur-of-the-moment video just
explaining what we want in somebody we
thought it would be a fun idea
and creative to make like a video
submission where basically people could
go and like submit their own video
of why they should come work with us and
admittedly in our first video it didn't
go over
so well uh it was horrible i saw it i
was like
why do you guys keep mentioning laundry
like you guys just your jokes did not
work
yeah it was a mistake you shouldn't be
making jokes
in like something that's like here's a
job posting yeah okay so i
actually technically wasn't supposed to
be like a joke per se
but basically like we were trying to
emphasize the fact that whoever we ended
up hiring
it's likely they could be doing less
than glamorous work sometimes
because the purpose of the assistant
would be to alleviate
and like give more time back to graham
and i so we kind of like went in
for an example like what if they needed
to do laundry sometime because we were
like really
busy working or something like that i
mean a purpose of an assistant is to
give your
give you your time back and basically
people got upset at us
for saying the laundry thing yes yeah
but like instead of
saying you know they're you're going to
be doing less than glamorous work you're
like
do laundry and that's the only thing you
didn't say do laundry
you said it might include yeah you said
it like it might include us
doing laundry and then i was like yeah
you don't want to do jack's laundry like
it's bad
and then we kind of joked around about
it and then i thought it was a great
video i
i didn't even think i put a second
thought and then once i started seeing
comments like dude
i can't believe it you're looking for
somebody to do jack's laundry and i
showed it to macy and he's like why did
you throw that in there
that's really bad like is it that bad
see the thing is you and i
we think alike insofar as like we
wouldn't mind doing someone's laundry i
feel happy
if that means that we can work with with
like a job that we we would like to work
with people we like
but we have to do laundry i would do it
in a heartbeat same but it doesn't
matter to me i'm competent
at doing laundry i've done laundry first
i'm not terrible
you've done laundry like three times
you've been together and you have
turned your clothes pink i think one or
two of those times and another yeah
but that was the first one the first one
yeah the blank you didn't tell me
i had to do the blanket on low heat
anyway you didn't even know that
that didn't matter the point the point
is basically
that uh when i started working i was
doing anything like
literally anything i could i was doing
all the grunt work i was uh
like going and picking up like check
checkbooks from somebody's
car and like driving like across the
town just to pick up like a key or like
just little stuff
i didn't ask for anything in return same
with jack i think jack when you started
a whole bunch of just miscellaneous
stuff
that just sucked to do but it was just a
part of the job so that's that's the
point we were trying to emphasize
didn't hit people didn't understand it
and uh so we came back with another
video
and that's when you saw you saw our
video how did you see it alex
yeah i mean um so i work from home so
once i was done with my shift
um basically i was on instagram and i
follow you
at gp stefan and nice plug
wow he's a natural wow
that was great that was good that's the
whole reason why we hired you right
that's gonna be that
just a plug and um you know i just saw
his story that he was hiring and
i don't think it was the first time he
posted it because
um when i searched graham's stuff an
assistant on youtube
there was already like maybe two videos
or three
um at least that popped up for me and
you know that's when i that's when i saw
it and i kind of felt
compelled to apply and i don't know if
you guys want to go into the story now
i do oh let's see yeah let me tell you
guys so i saw it i was out of my shift
and i was like
man this would be an awesome opportunity
i was like
i felt a calling and so the first thing
i did i told kelsey
which is my girlfriend i'm gonna apply
i'm gonna hop in the shower
i look like a werewolf so i scheduled
the haircut while
um hopped in the shower went to get my
hair cut after i got my hair cut
i was searching because i was coming up
with ideas and i was gonna do the coffee
thing that
i uh for those of you guys that didn't
see the video i wrote out
smash the like button in in coffee but
um i had to research where to buy i
don't drink coffee by the way
um so i had to strike once more for us
scram yeah that's a good
that's what i said so i had to figure
out where to buy the
like the same coffee maker that you had
in your video the same coffee
the same coffee creamer the same filters
and um i did that while i was getting my
haircuts on my phone
and i figured out that it was like a
like a kroger brand
so went to one of the the chains picked
up the stuff
and that same night i uh i filmed that
video
i'll tell you my initial impression it i
this was within the first like 24 hours
i think of my
of of my instagram post going live uh
i saw your video and instantly i was
like this is it i remember even going to
bc
yeah really oh yeah no he ran back and
he's like found the guy
i found it and i was like okay okay
just let's let's look at everyone else
he's like don't watch the videos like oh
you found it yeah yeah yeah yeah you
found it yeah macy agreed with me
and this is like we had a week by the
way of more submissions
i just felt like first of all you were
very prompt
and so i get sometimes there's an
advantage of kind of being late to the
game and like seeing what other people
are doing and
improving on that but you were on it and
at that point i'm like
you know mentally i was almost like you
know why even look for anybody else of
course
we weren't going to do that and we were
going to look through everybody and give
everyone an equal chance i told jack
this
and jack was very much like graham we
got to look through everybody
you you can't do this we don't no uh uh
you're jumping the gun yeah
i thought it was unfair to say in the
first 24 hours that we've already picked
someone i wasn't going to say we're
going to pick someone well
yeah but like we probably should have if
we had made up our mind because people
were still posting
my mind but i thought you said you had
made up your mind you wanted him
mentally but like i would but we hadn't
met yet like we
all should watch it yeah i just knew
based on the video i just i felt like
this is this is it
so i saw his video i thought it was
really good i thought it was i mean it
was my favorite video definitely by that
time but at that time
graham was so early on to it and he
wanted to jump the gun and i said
no we have to wait for everyone else to
submit their videos because
what if we like make up our mind but we
don't publish anything anywhere and then
people are still submitting videos
after we already and people are just
wasting their time you know and i felt
like
it was wrong to set a deadline and then
just pick someone in the first 24 hours
yeah so we did just that and uh
we looked through everybody and i
remember you sent me one from colby
colby baker colby baker that video i
was blown away now jack told me listen
alex's alex seems pretty good but watch
colby's video
i like colby's video a lot just wait
until you see it we got an argument in
the car
yeah like on the way we were just we're
driving around
we got an argument because i i forget
what what that was about macy do you
remember what was the
argument about he ate that argument
because you guys have two different they
have two different communication styles
so they'll be saying the same thing at
each other and then you're in the car
you're just like i
want to bash my head through this window
right now shut up you're saying the same
thing
that was like the only oh sorry i just
so their argument was is like
oh i think this is the right one but um
we should see everybody and they both
were saying that in different ways back
and forth at each other and i literally
was
like what is wrong with you that was it
we both were saying the same thing yeah
i was saying i like alex and colby but
we should meet them both
and then jack was saying we shouldn't
pick one of them until we meet
both of them yeah and we just i don't
know something wasn't wasn't hidden
there
yeah there's gonna be someone at home
this just like understands my
frustration of hearing this for 20
minutes in the car we were driving from
somewhere that was like all the way
across town
and it was just whole drive
yeah and i was like okay i'm gonna throw
up wow
i'll admit you showed me colby's video i
was
really impressed colby's video by the
way uh for those that will we should put
a few little clips of it on here
it was so entertaining to watch i felt
like from
a creative standpoint colby just from a
filming standpoint
this was a 10 out of 10 this video it
was so creative it was filmed so well
and just the humor behind it i felt
would make for a
really entertaining either vlog episode
or just a person to work with in general
so it was close but before we made the
final decision we actually sat down for
probably like what was that like two and
a half hours
looking through every single submission
that everyone has made we watched them
all
so if you submitted we watched it we saw
you we know you we know who you are it
was over two and a half hours i think
graham was spending at least 30 minutes
a day if not more
oh yeah every single one and even myself
too i know i was spending quite a bit of
time because i was just curious like i
wasn't part of the decision but i wanted
to see
like kind of get my first impressions
because obviously like you're in the
house all the time i wanted to see
who possibly could be yeah yeah in the
living space
i was scoping out the competition yeah
you know i was like
no i thought they were all good and um i
kind of wanted to see because i was so
early
i really did want to see okay what is
everybody else doing because
i kind of just shot blindly and i was
like i hope it hits
and i don't know there wasn't
a established set of videos yet and and
so
yeah it felt really blind to me yeah i
think you had this nice mix for me
because like there was a few like there
was a few i was
kind of rooting for that like either
they seemed really hard working
but they didn't have the technical
skills yet but they seemed like they
would learn
yeah and so it's like really i thought
that was really cool but you seemed to
be hardworking you would learn new
skills but you already kind of had some
stuff to bring to the table
as well as being like having humor in
your video
and just technical skills with it that
you were bringing to the table that you
just had this nice
jack of all trades where some people
might have had one or two of those
traits you just seem to have all of them
which made it work really well
yeah it was tough we had it must have
been like 10 or 15 different tabs open
and what we would do we'd watch all the
videos if we liked somebody we'd keep
the tab open open up another tab
we got like 15 tabs open to people and
then we watched them all again back to
back we're like
between these two people what do you
like okay we like this one and we slowly
narrowed it down and really it was be it
was between you and colby
and that was that was uh your your big
competition there
so we decided what we would do is fly
each of you out to las vegas and give
you a test
and you showed up you were dressed
10 out of 10 very spiffy you were over
dressed for the uk where were
you wait isn't that how i'm dressed now
yeah you were wearing dress shoes
which i think was a little intimidating
i still wore them today they still
weren't yeah
we're basically just wearing sweatpants
and stuff like i wouldn't expect you to
show up in sweatpants but
you were dressed you were overdressed
yeah so i think the thing with that
is um i don't buy a lot of clothes
i i have a set of clothes a few clothes
that i like and that's what i have and
so over the years i phased out any
t-shirts because i was working in the
corporate world it's like
why am i going to spend my money on a
t-shirt when the only thing i wear
is to work and i could wear the things
that i wear to work on the weekends so
um being here is kind of different
because
the other day i went with kelsey and i
bought my first t-shirt and watched wow
yeah so i know it sounds so ridiculous
but
it really is a huge a huge thing for me
you're going to have to get your
honorary pair of sweatpants that way
yeah that's all we wear around here now
pants so tell us what were you doing
first of all before
doing all of this and then what was your
reaction
when we reached out to you yeah so
before this
um i was working at a bank and i was
working from home
and i was working in operations so what
i did was
move money around so other teams would
send us files
um we'd upload them into the system you
know like millions of dollars they'd get
moved
and uh reconciling like internal bank
accounts so really boring stuff
basically in excel all day and uh
when you guys reached out to me it was
ridiculous i think um well graham saw my
video within the first 10 minutes
that i posted i don't know if you knew
that no i didn't first 10
15 minutes you saw it you responded i
just scroll i'm
constantly refreshing to watch all the
videos so yeah you were on there
and when i got the message i i was
luckily i was at home and i told kelsey
and we were just like
oh my gosh but then i was also like
maybe he's reaching out to like fifty
percent of the people like i had no clue
but when it really turned real was when
you guys both reached out to me
to say hey we want to fly you out which
is kind of where you were going towards
and i was just like
oh this is real like like now
i didn't know how many people you had in
mind but i knew that
there only has to be a handful of people
at this point because i was like
graham is so frugal he's not going to
buy a bunch of people playing tickets
i was like how many could he possibly
fly that was a joke but it's kind of
true
yeah no it's true it's true so what were
your thoughts about moving to las vegas
because you'd have to relocate you
weren't living here but first i want to
thank our sponsor notion
notion is a powerful tool that improves
team collaboration and can also help you
stay organized on your own notion lets
you take notes
manage tasks set goals and so much more
when i was in college it was super
important for me to keep all my notes
and schoolwork organized for all the
different classes i was taking and of
course not to mention all of the work i
had to do with grant
fortunately for me a friend showed me
notion notion was able to help me
quickly create a custom layout for all
my notes so i could organize them
exactly how i wanted although i'm no
longer in college i still use notion all
the time
in fact it's the program that we use to
track all of our sponsors for the
podcast i have a custom shared sheet
with my sponsor agent where we can
easily track and manage all of our
deadlines
i personally love how notion has tables
that i can easily add formulas to check
boxes so i can make a custom list
and it also has a collection of
templates in case i don't want to use my
own custom layout i was actually
extremely happy to hear that notion
reached out to sponsor this podcast
because i've had
nothing but great experiences with them
in the years that i've been using it it
really is easy to see why so many
businesses and individuals use notion
sign up for notion with the link in the
description and get started today thank
you so much notion for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast
right so my first thought was
scorpions i told jack this i'm terrified
i don't know what spider lobsters
that's what they are like yeah exactly i
mean i told jack i was like
i was like i'm i'm i'll deal with the
heat the only thing that for some reason
creeps me out is i know that we're in
the desert
and there's creepy crawlies and i'm okay
with most of them but
scorpions that was my only concern
is that a weird have you have you seen a
scorpion before
um yes there was a traumatic event so
yeah
one time i was sleeping um in a house in
mexico with my mom
and my mom in the middle of the night i
just hear a giant
smack and what it was was i was sleeping
near
the bed by the wall and my mom had woken
up in the middle of night saw scorpion
on the wall she took a like a shoe
and she like smacked it on the wall and
it woke me up and so
imagine waking up to like scorpion being
like right next to you so
maybe that's it but i didn't really see
it because it was dark
they're pretty harmless oh no they're
terrifying though if you've ever seen
them in person
i had one time when i was staying in um
in like a foreign country and it was
like a really really tropical area
uh they would like to hide if you left
like a beach towel
on the floor and it was damp underneath
so i went to go pick mine up and it just
like fell
out and it was like oh my goodness
there's a baby and it was terrified i
wanted the
scorpion as a kid my dad was all for it
but
i split time between my dad's house my
mom's house
and my mom just did not want a scorpion
and uh didn't get a scorpio i really
wanted she was actually fine with the
tarantula
believe it or not i had a tarantula for
like eight years but no scorpion no
scorpio i really wanted a scorpion and
they're so cool too when they glow under
the black light
i love that that is so neat you guys
don't think so no
i agree i i think it'd be cool like i'd
be okay if you had it as a pet in the
house and i'd be like oh cool
just why like i don't want to find a
scorpion under my towel
to be fair i have um we have you know
friends that live out here like
jeremy from financial education his wife
and his wife said that they've only
found two
and they were both in the garage yeah
well i think
she said like you just get your house
sprayed right here yeah i think to
summarize
i think that it was a bigger deal in my
head than it really is
because since i've been out here i know
they come out at night but
i don't think i have to worry about it i
think i'll probably see one or two like
you know like you do a spider in your
house and i'll get over it but other
than that
the only other thing that i that in my
the back of my head was like
oh should i move to vegas um kelsey and
i both have family
you know not too far where we live but
luckily we've lived away
from them uh for about three years now
three
three and a half years and so that
wasn't really a huge issue
and where'd you come from oh right i'm
from wisconsin so milwaukee wisconsin
um originally from the northern suburbs
of illinois though so it's all
within like a one and a half to our
drive and when you flew out here there
was a little bit of a mishap
oh tell tell them this is unbelievable
okay so i got here and
you know graham and jack asked me oh how
was your flight and you know
i was straight up honest with them i was
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie to
you guys so i told them the truth
and and here's what happened you don't
know this may say i don't know oh yeah
this is good so listen to this um so i
was so excited i was getting to the
airport maybe like two hours before my
flight because i'm like
can't miss this flight you know gotta be
on time i get to the airport
and it turns out that i had booked my
flight for the wrong day
and i had no ticket and i was just stuck
in the airport
no ticket i have to see graham and jack
tomorrow at eight in the morning
what am i gonna do so i pull out my
phone and i see that there's one more
flight leaving milwaukee
in 20 minutes so i run to the delta
desk because it was through delta and i
paid
800 bucks for a one-way ticket
to come to las vegas and
you know do a trial run with graham and
jack that's committed
that is committed i i was a little
hesitant
but i couldn't miss the opportunity i
mean and
and when you guys told me i didn't want
it to be like
i'm a pretty honest person and i didn't
i didn't want to be like oh it was good
because it was ridiculous it's crazy so
yeah that's
um that's that's kind of what happened
so it was unlucky but it was also lucky
that there was another flight we we comp
we paid we gave him money we didn't give
him
800 but we gave him we gave him a flight
we paid for his initial flight oh yeah
housing and everything yeah jack and
graham agreed to give me you know a 100
yeah 400 for flights and and
accommodations
which in vegas is pretty easy flights
are pretty cheap
and uh yeah one flight surpassed the
budget by double that's nuts
but yeah but i mean it paid off you know
yeah and i remember too when you showed
up i was really impressed because you
printed out this whole like
booklet of ways that we could improve
and make more money on the channel
and i i like i like to pull little
pranks every now and then and
i get this book and it's so nicely done
and i open the first page and like
it's a typo right here i i had only
known graham for like 20 minutes at that
point
yeah i was like because we were gonna
film and so i was like
well i may as well give him this because
you know there's going to be free time
or whatever
yeah any and he pulled that prank on me
and my heart just dropped i was like
oh my gosh i spent all night on this
booklet i had my girlfriend proofread it
and i was like there's got to be a typo
in there because i did it at like three
in the morning but i was like on the
first page
like that would be ridiculous but good
good job
good job so as soon as you arrived to
las vegas
what happened what were your first
impressions of graham and i and macy
be honest be percent honest yeah so
don't don't to be honest i in my head i
was like
i didn't think i would get along with
jack as well as we do
and i i mentioned this to jack a little
bit why why not
because you know jack to me like i
i knew we would get along i i just
didn't think we'd be like
bffs you know you guys were in separate
i was actually really surprised it's
just like how much
you just hang out outside of work like
pizzas yeah
they made these pizzas last night right
yeah so it's like work ends and then you
guys are just hanging out right
yeah yeah because so in my head i was
like
well jack and i kind of i like i was
like we come from
very different backgrounds i was like
you know
jack kind of like he seemed like almost
like a college bro to me
you know and and i was just like you
know
i was like grammy he seems a little bit
more like calm
macy seems you know calm i was like but
jack i was like
i think he's gonna i think we're gonna
get along but we're not gonna be like
super close
and i'm being honest here guys i know i
love it
here and it's the complete opposite
because
jack and i the first thing that we
talked about are microphones and how
we have to convince graham to buy sure
sm7bs
and not that we don't love road you know
road is absolutely
cool thank you brod great great company
right right in australia too man
but no we the first thing we bonded over
was like really weird techie stuff and
it just kept going like we like um
so we're like we both have a really wide
range of music that we like
um we both well he actually he took me
out
to the strip oh like my first year i
know
i know you sent me a picture of both of
you on the strip by like
one of the casinos i was like oh man
that seems like so much fun just for a
walk yeah we didn't do
anything we literally because jack was
like have you ever seen the strip and i
was like no because i never visited
vegas before
and um so he took me out and since then
i got to say jack
like i don't have any friends out here
and i hang out with jack every day
and no how did you do it with you ever
since
same thing yeah so yeah that's uh my
first impression of you
um it was you were so candid man i
showed up graham answers the door
and he's just like oh yeah like we have
a podcast he's like
he's like i gotta hop in the shower and
i'm just like
i'm like he did he did say to show up at
like eight or nine a.m
and i looked i was like yeah no no i was
like so like
the fact that it was so candid was just
incredible
and then yeah let's see what did i think
of macy don't keep doing me keep doing
me
okay let's talk about ground let's take
a look talk about me more talk about me
more yeah so this
we woke up 15 minutes before you got
here because we end up staying up super
we end up
working until like eight or nine at
night so then he and i want to spend
time together so we stay up till like
midnight or later so let me sleep until
about eight
right so that makes sense so but i just
thought it was hilarious that he knows
i'm showing up at x amount of time
or at x time and then i show up and he's
like oh yeah what's up alex
and then the first thing graham says to
me is alex
whatever you want from the refrigerator
man he's like he's like
he's like go ahead just and then um
i was so odd because i was like uh and
then i looked and i forgot that you guys
had the mini fridge
yeah so there's like three things to
pick from
yeah yeah and i was like i was like i
didn't know what to pick from so luckily
macy peer pressured me she was like
she's like take the uh there's butternut
squash ravioli
so while macy and graham stepped out i
made myself some
butternut squash ravioli see my thought
was that we we had a podcast guest
coming at like 11.
you were showing up at like eight eight
thirty ish so my thought was that like
jack and you would do your thing i would
get ready and i would show up by the
time we had to film
so but uh but yeah i think you came and
i just wanted to open the door and
introduce myself
yeah no that was super nice i think it
would have been a little odd if i was
in here and i was like oh where's graham
um
graham's just a simulation yeah
what did you guys think of me like i
know you said i was overdressed but
what were your initial impressions
because i know you saw the video
right so you might have had a a
preconceived notion
maybe of of what i was like but you were
the exact same from the video as you
were in person
yeah i don't i don't think there's any
difference whatsoever
oh you know what you know what the thing
i liked what kind of sealed the deal for
me
but first i want to thank our sponsor
ladder life is amazing and full of
beautiful surprises
whether my ears are being blessed by my
favorite pianist i'm admiring the
inspiring marine life at my favorite
lookout or i'm eating all-you-can-eat
sushi with some of my best friends
it's moments like these that act as a
constant reminder of how beautiful life
is and exactly why it should be
protected on that note it makes sense
why people get life insurance especially
long-term coverage which is surprisingly
affordable why not pay a little bit each
month to protect the ones that you love
if you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder ladder makes it
impressively fast
and easy to get covered you just need a
few minutes and a phone or a laptop to
apply ladder smart algorithms work in
real time so you'll find out instantly
if you're approved
and there are no hidden fees and you can
cancel at any time and since life
insurance costs more as you age now is
the perfect time to cross it off your
list
so check out ladder today to see if
you're instantly approved go to
ladderlife.com
iced coffee that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life
dot com slash iced coffee ladderlife.com
iced coffee
thank you so much ladder for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
you started cleaning up the kitchen oh
that was
huge we have a friend this is you know
big shout out to anthony anthony's
garage on youtube
he is a clean freak so anything he sees
out of place even if you don't ask him
like if he sees like a little
you know something on the ground he'll
just pick it up and throw it away you
never have to ask him
you did that in the kitchen there was
something in the kitchen like the dishes
or something like that you started just
cleaning up everything around the
kitchen
we didn't even ask you to do that right
that was huge
i think i cooked dinner for everybody
but my ankle was really shocked it was
like i cannot do the dishes afterwards
it's like i'll get it tomorrow morning
and then i woke up the next morning and
walked out and all the dishes were done
i was like
oh i appreciate it keep that up don't
stop doing that
anytime you see something it needs to be
just clean it up
clean it up we notice yeah i mean it's
not you know and i think
i mentioned this like it's not like i
was trying to
you know kind of do it it's more of like
like if there's i'm not i wouldn't say
i'm like anthony where if i see a piece
of paper over there it's freaking me out
but if i'm walking past that piece of
paper
am i just gonna kick it to the side like
what am i supposed to
jack that hasn't understood
gosh jack your room hey jack oh it was
so bad
red so the door in there the door was
open and ramsay ran
in there open and then ramsay was in
there odor coming it wasn't there
no ramsay went in there
i had to go and pick out ramsay from
your room it was like
like something like something blew up in
the room are you kidding me no i'm not
kidding
whoa hold on slow your roll just what
you couldn't even see the carpet
because we have stuff everywhere mats
and rugs in there
no you couldn't see the mats and it was
just the whole thing was completely
covered like you had to step around
okay so truth be told we don't have a
dresser
or anything in the room you have a huge
closet but i don't have any hangers
i don't have any hangers i i
they're on their way they're on the way
they've been they've been on the way for
months well they're coming did they get
lost
look i it's not it's not as bad as you
guys think you have a huge walk-in
closet amazon sent it to china i've
never had such an impact and then they
went back to china and that's the deal
yeah so don't worry about that guys it's
not that dirty
after jack and i have been making dinner
every night we've been cleaning up you
know yeah
very well yeah i've noticed and i
noticed i do the dishes after
you cook two like fifty percent of the
time you do yeah you do you do help me
clean up
afterwards jack doesn't know how to use
a dishwasher though but that's a story
for a different day we don't talk about
graham doesn't know about that we don't
talk about it yeah we don't talk about
that he doesn't know how to use a uh
uh iron either that's that that's that's
true was that the
the day that you get yeah okay so the
day that i come to film this podcast
jack goes to put on his uh his weeble
shirt for the podcast and he comes out
and it's full of wrinkles and we all
look and amazing graham and i are
standing there and we just look at him
and we're just like
you're not gonna wear that to the
podcast are you and jax just looks at us
like yeah what's wrong with it
and i think macy's the one who's like
jack go get the iron i'll get the iron
for you just
iron your shirt and but you know i mean
it was really bad but yeah okay so it
looks like somebody folded the shirt and
then ironed it folded that's how bad
yeah
the whole thing was crazy but you guys
were so surprised i didn't know how to
use an iron right but my logic is
how are you just born knowing how to use
an iron well my favorite part was when
the seam was coming out of it you're
like ah
graham it's leaking yeah oh i spilled
water everywhere you pick it up
there's water in this i still the water
everywhere i'm like yeah they're
supposed to be what you're supposed you
but you plug it in
why is your water if you plug it in
i'm not that bad guys yeah
but now i know how to use an iron yeah i
walked up to alex i'm like welcome to my
insanity
welcome what were your initial
impressions of alex
um alex didn't do his initial
impressions of me
it was a little different because i i
don't think i saw
well i saw macy a little bit but then
she kind of went to do her own thing for
the day
um but my initial impressions were
she's literally just like her youtube
videos like
literally the same personality like i
don't know how to explain it it's just
the vibe that she gives off is the same
but she was super nice because she did
the same thing that graham said she's
like
grab left basically and she's like oh by
the way alex grab anything out of the
fridge
i'm like oh okay i see the the type of
uh house this is but
no super nice super accommodating um
because
and and i could tell i think macy
was interested in having another girl in
the house like my girlfriend
because um i think i think one of the
first things she said to me is like
oh i really like how you have a
girlfriend did you say that
i did because i said then there's gonna
be another girl around
cause you know how many times i'm like
okay guys i did my nails and they're
like
ah and i'm like i'm like what color
should i do my nails next because after
you know you
do them all the time it's just they go
um
blue or something but i was like oh so
there's another girl so she'll get it
i'll have somebody do face masks with
and drink wine out by the pool
yeah we don't we don't get that stuff
no um that was my i didn't have many
crazy thoughts about me as much as you
guys i didn't really watch her videos
too much but
from what i saw exactly
the same yeah super nice and then your
impressions of alex
okay my impressions of you um this might
have been a little bit
of projecting because granted i worked
corporate and then i went youtube
kind of similar to what you did i
thought with my
my perspective on how you go from that
to that i thought you were ready to step
into a world that isn't as structured as
the corporate world but it has like a
lot of room for fast growth it's a
little bit more volatile
i thought you would be able to handle
that really well some of that might have
been just because i went from doing that
and i was like
or maybe it's just that i did it and
then i recognized you that you'd be able
to handle it too
i thought from like i think like five
minutes of you walking in and i was like
i
hope they pick him because i feel so
comfortable with him in the house
like you know we left you up and like
you're doing your thing on your computer
in the dining room and i like walk out
to go grab myself a snack and it didn't
feel uncomfortable
it was really nice it was just like i
hope they pick him
because he just feels like he was
supposed to be in this house
if that makes sense so um and you know
this is this is nothing against colby at
all or any of this that i'm saying it's
just
i felt like you belonged in the house
and part of the group and then watching
you interact with us while we're eating
dinner it just felt like you were this
piece that we
didn't know we needed as part of the
team or part of the fam here
uh so i just i thought you were just
like oh this piece that
was gonna you were gonna be able to
handle it really well you were here
to come you were gonna give it a
thousand percent and
um i just overall had like was just
excited to have you around
so you got here we did a lot of work
that day it was a very very busy day
you were able to actually edit that
podcast that we filmed on saturday
and have it completely done by the next
morning
on sunday and that was rough i remember
that first night that saturday
you and i were both up until it was like
what was it three in the morning
3 30 in the morning we were editing that
podcast just me and him in the kitchen
at the big table
side by side going through final cut pro
editing the podcast
and that was definitely an experience
and i'm glad
that you were you were totally willing
and ready to to pump that out and the
next day i think you arrived back here
at like
no you spent the night and then you were
up at like eight oh yeah yeah originally
i was gonna leave sunday my flight was
on sunday but i booked the flight for
the wrong day
so i didn't have a returning flight back
so that's when i
was like oh it'd be cool like stay one
more day because
i was also trying to get a feel for it
too like i wanted it to be
fun like i was like can i really see
myself doing this
and i know like everybody's like what do
you mean like
i want to be a youtuber or whatever but
like you have to think about it in real
life like
like you have to be ready to know that
this is going to phase into some part
of your life and it's going to mix and
you're going to be stressed and
and it's different than working in nine
to five you clock out
and i can do whatever i want it's
completely different and so um
i was like you know what a second day
might be might be fun
so i actually told jack i was like if
you guys or i think i told you
yeah i was like if you need help the
next day i was like i'm not planning on
leaving until monday
just let me know and you said well i'm
gonna be busy all that day because i'm
planning
but you were like but if jack needs help
which i did
which he did and i was like yeah jack
needs more help than any of us could
give him
that's because i have so many
responsibilities a lot of help yeah i
have a lot of responsibilities
so i don't think anybody could give you
the help that you need so
what's going on with this today huh
what's going on you guys set off the
fire alarm
oh okay i remember that okay
i thought that was macy's cooking and i
went out to see macy i'm like why is the
fire
because we have sprinklers and new
constructions when
uh when it senses there's like a fire
since the smoke the sprinklers go off
and
i didn't know that equipment and we got
a piano like we got a lot of stuff that
could get ruined
yeah so essentially so what happened the
second day was basically
alex and i woke up and we're actually
planning on creating a full-on podcast
studio
in the room right now that i'm using as
my office and we were installing these
foam
like acoustic panels or something on the
ceiling
and in order to do that you have to have
like a spray adhesive
so you can like get them to stick
together
and basically alex and i worked on that
for i don't even know how long it was
that day
it was all day that we were just
sticking foam panels on the ceiling
which is like very high almost out of
reach very dangerous activity yeah
because jack ordered a spray online
specifically for the phone so as we're
spraying it and the room is
filling up with like glue chemicals
particulates particulate yeah uh glue
particularly
jack and i look at each other and we're
like uh is this safe and i was like yeah
yeah let's just go put on our mask
so we put on our masks as we're like
spraying like the covet mask no by the
way literally
like it looked like a laboratory like in
there it was
white no it literally did like i
remember you walked in there and you're
like whoa
what's going on i walked in and it
looked like uh like the whole room was
filled up of steam
[Music]
and they kept the door closed didn't
open the window
we didn't want the door open because
anyone would spill into you guys yeah
that was the only
consideration we didn't want the animals
going in there but still it was like
yeah so
anyway the the thick particulate
set off the fire alarms and it made
graham come out of
the office because he was planning and
macy was in the middle of filming a
cooking video
and i'm the new guy who's just like hey
sorry for setting off your fire alarm it
was a big ordeal
it was an ordeal i'm confused because i
pick cookies but i always like them like
a minute or two under done so it's like
there's
no way i burn these macy's set off the
fire alarm though
a few times i've done that quite a few
but it's usually cooking like meat or
something and she
she'll forget to put on the fan yeah and
usually if you're cooking the meat the
the steam is going everywhere we got a
smoke alarm right next to it so it goes
off every now and then
right no that that makes sense it
definitely she took out the cookies
early
i was like there's no way but you rushed
to macy
and you were like because you knew she
was baking and i think you were like
missy did you burn the cookies
and then that's when you guys that's
when we came out and we were like it was
scary i didn't
when you said the sprinkler thing i was
freaking out on the inside i was like oh
my god are we gonna just destroy tens of
thousands of dollars worth of stuff
yeah fortunately the sprinklers didn't
come on everything went fine
except for the fact that now all of the
panels are falling from the ceiling yeah
so again we're gonna have to do it again
which is the biggest pain in the butt
but it's fine
for old time's sake we're gonna do it
again yeah for old time's sake and guys
look out because we're actually ordering
a big table and we're going to set up
that as a podcast studio it's going to
be
incredible yeah please open a window
this next time we will
yeah yeah afterwards yeah yeah
absolutely
jack won't remember alex i'm thanking
you
i'll remember but anyways those were our
two days with you alex
and they were great days and we really
loved spending that time with you and we
knew you were a great candidate from
then
it was where selling macy when you left
it sounds weird to say i missed you
being here
yeah yeah it was weird but it just felt
like it was different like it just
wasn't the same
after you had left it's true and it was
like i missed having you here like i
just
i like just having you around the house
even if we don't talk or like i'm i'm in
here doing my thing it's just
it's cool to have you just in the living
room working on just whatever it's just
it's nice
yeah i move around i yeah i use the i
use the kitchen table the living room
um i've even used like the guest bed
like i
and i've told alex just just hang out
here just if you if you want to just
hang out over a weekend just
even if you're not working just come and
show up and hang out i don't mind use
the
use the guest bedroom i don't care he
has a good price to come over yeah
yeah i will say um that's one thing that
that shocked me
when um when i came over i
i mean graham the first week that i was
here he was gone
and one of the first things he's like
yeah you want to come to my house and
make dinner he's like i'm not there
but he's like go ahead and just i was
just like oh
and it was very very odd you're very uh
because we're we're still small we have
a close crew so
i guess it's pretty nice right yeah so
your presence was great and uh that was
our experience with you on that first
time we flew you out and we had those
two days with you then we had colby fly
out
and i'm i was really excited with colby
and he met all of my expectations
colby was honestly he was great bobby
had a lot of strength colby's strength
in my opinion was was his creativity
i think his ability to add humor into
the video
was unparalleled it was so good
uh but then i then i thought like
overall like the entire
package i felt like sure you might not
have
his level of like humor creativity but
that's not something that
you you need right now and can't learn
in the future
yeah and i mean i i also told jack it
was a little bit different because
i was kind of doing a podcast where it
was very
cut cut um and then kobe got to edit a
vlog which i don't think you guys
mentioned he edited the first vlog so if
you guys saw
the first vlog on thus the family
subscribe
um your free stock down below in the
description
yeah worth up to fifty dollars and you
send it for public and i'm posting all
of my stock trades on there so if
you want to see what stocks i'm buying
it it's free it's basically
it's free money it's great you might as
well do it amazing
and then i'll buy wait oh actually if
we're posting this tomorrow
i'm doing a uh i'm gifting a tesla stock
to whoever signs up using the link down
below in the description deposit 100
on the platform and then friday april
16th
i'm going to be giving someone a free
share of tesla should do that yeah you
should awesome
yeah yeah so yeah just do that because
you may as well it's like it'll take you
a few minutes worth of work
best case scenario you get up to like
700 of a free stock
worst case scenario you spend like what
a minute two minutes signing up and you
get a free stock worth up to fifty
dollars
you win either way no matter what
happens free money free money
yeah um kobe got to edit the vlog and
that was awesome i got to edit the
podcast so not much creativity
now the second vlog which is going to be
out by the time that this is out
i got to edit the second vlog so i i
feel like for that i did get to do
get to be a little bit more creative
with the with the editing
um but i agree kobe i think i think
hobie's creativity it's great it's
insane yeah he wrote sponsor scripts for
us
for that podcast that released that
following weekend and the sponsor
scripts were hilarious
he's just so good at just creating like
structure and like telling a story
and all that stuff he's just got a great
sense of humor i just want to make sure
we're doing colby justice because he
really was
great and the thing is we had so many
people apply for this position
and so many people that were good enough
so many people
that would we know for a fact they would
blow yeah perfectly fine with us
we could do a great job with them and
they would they would be
better than good enough they would be
perfect for the position the unfortunate
thing is that we could only pick one
person so if we didn't end up picking
some of you that doesn't mean that you
guys were bad candidates we had so many
candidates that were like
i would have been so excited to work
with you guys yeah there were at least a
dozen
where if if if that was the only if we
just
if they showed up tomorrow i'd be like
oh yeah this is awesome
yeah which is so happy there's like a
dozen people like that that
were honestly it might be just pretty
much perfect
so not to discredit anyone else right
apply for the position or colby and
leave your videos up there
because we may not be done with just
alex like we
we may continue hiring at some point not
to mention i've spoken with a few other
people
who have started looking over those
videos and want to recruit people
who have submitted for me yeah wow
i won't mention any names but youtubers
yes yes other people that need help me
at some point in the future there was a
few that i saw that it was like
ooh okay if they don't pick them at some
point in the future when i get to
meeting someone for that stuff i'll keep
them all up there we have a great pool
of people that applied for the position
so
thank you guys yeah and i'll be honest
you know getting here and speaking of
all these other candidates
man you guys needed help badly like how
busy are you
extremely busy i mean i went back home
easter weekend
right and um i shot a wedding because i
do photography
and after the wedding i mean i stayed up
editing a podcast until four in the
morning
and i mean i could have done it at
different times right
but just need having to get it out there
and working and it doesn't feel like
work
that's the weird part jack and graham
keep me extremely busy
and i feel like if this keeps going the
way
that it is you're gonna need more help
yeah where do you see yourself in five
years
where do you see this going well to be
honest i hope i can
your graham in five years and here flip
the tables
yeah i'll come work for you in in five
years
if ideally i'd love to stay here in five
years i
this is like what i love to do i was
like i'm so glad i got this opportunity
in five years i'd love to see myself
kind of like
i don't want to say in jack's role but
like kind of what jack's role
has evolved into i'd love to
um i think when we talked on the phone i
mentioned how i'd love to grow
the way that we produce content um i
won't necessarily get into it but
it involves hiring more people and i'd
love to help run that operation
as smoothly as possible and i think i
have the benefit of
coming from the corporate world but i
also don't want to force corporate
structure
because i think part of what makes this
weird machine run that is
youtube creation is some of the some of
the messiness like
it sounds kind of crazy but i think you
need i think you need structure
but i also think that not having
structure
is also a good balance so ideally in
five years
i'd love to be in a position where i'm
able to help
uh the graham stuff and brand i guess
grow and
and people won't even know that we do it
that's what i like yeah but i would like
to see you eventually doing other things
in addition to what you're doing now and
growing whatever that is like you've
started doing that
the iced coffee hour clips channel down
below in the description
great thumbnails by the way i like those
thumbnails thanks yeah
so so stuff like that i i'd love to take
on more projects too in the next five
years
um but i can also tell that
we're gonna we're gonna be busy we're
there's gonna be a limit
we're gonna keep creating so much
content that we're gonna
probably need i'm not gonna say now but
you might need another person eventually
was there ever any moment when you were
here that you were like
okay this is it this is what i want to
do yeah
i i think the moment where i knew that
this was for me was after jack and i
hung all those
foam panels because that was grueling
work
you were just high yeah you didn't have
to be mildly
delirious you ruined so many brain cells
you're like yeah i want to work here
no i i think after that because what
happened was like
um jack it made sense for jack to be on
the ladder he's like a thin guy over
here
i was on the ladder and he was i was i
was holding the ladder and then i was
also
um like grabbing the foam from the floor
spraying it handing it up to jack
so it was a lot of like moving all day
from probably like
eight or nine in the morning we probably
didn't finish till like seven
it was and so when i finished doing that
and it felt like i had just you know
when you help a buddy with a project
and and you're just like oh let's like
let's go get dinner afterwards
when i felt that feeling after just
doing
labor all day i was just like this is it
like what more could i ask for i mean
you know you guys said that there there
would be things that
aren't editing like hanging foam tiles
and to be to be done with that and just
feeling like i just
i just spent a day with with my my best
friend that i didn't
it was awesome it didn't feel like work
it felt like two go
two bros two guys just like building a
deck in their free time
yeah building a deck building a deck two
college brothers
on the fun too you know yeah do frat
bros exactly
down
that's funny though that you said that
hanging up all of those pads was kind of
like your aha moment
and i think for me it was the exact same
thing but we flew you out before we flew
colby out and i wanted to make sure that
we gave colby a fair shot
at the position at the same time but
that was kind of my moment where i was
like oh okay
i could definitely see myself working
with this guy i would be so happy and
and lucky to have this guy on the team
very very happy with the four of us
right
it's a great great group yep how did you
find the channel originally
um i found the channel so i wasn't
always into personal finance and
you know i've had some conversations
with jack there was a point where i've
maxed out my credit cards
so that's an interesting story but um
i didn't grow up in a financially
literate household
my parents were immigrants and so
when i was working at a bank uh just as
like a customer service rep before i was
you know where i was but back then i saw
these people with a bunch of money they
would get like
10 grand every two weeks or 10 grand
every month
and it would be at zero in their living
paycheck to paycheck and they're asking
me to reverse their fees
and i'm like you're making so much more
money than me
i shouldn't be having to reverse any
fees for you like what's going on
and so i think at that point i
i almost got scared so i just wanted to
get educated
and and be financially literate so the
first person i ever found on youtube
when i was like searching about finances
was jeremy financial education
and i didn't watch his vid like i wasn't
like i didn't watch every video
the only thing i remember was like holy
smokers the same no
joke we gotta all do it at the same time
ready
three two one holy smokers
his story about like working at the gas
station and i was like oh that's cool
and then the youtube algorithm just
grabbed me people they pulled me away
from jeremy
then they fed me some meet kevin and
they're like oh you like me kevin
you know so i did watch me kevin a
little bit but then
they fed me graham stefan yeah and um
yeah so i'm lucky that i followed you on
instagram
because if i didn't i wouldn't have
applied
that's a sign to follow us yeah on
instagram gps
yes at jls selby
so out of curiosity you said you'd
watched a few of my videos was that
after you applied for graham
no yeah before yeah because everybody
apparently in the comments just calls
you graham's girlfriend
but i was curious i was like who is like
who is graham's girlfriend
and so you know and then i was confused
because i thought your name was savannah
so before i didn't know your real name
because you don't say it
well now you do but no i do you didn't
say it in your youtube videos so i was
like
so i was like wait so is her name is her
name savannah
or is it is it me so i knew
so i knew before i left that your name
was amazing so what was one thing that
really surprised you about us
and then maybe what was another thing
that was something that is like
generally assumed about us and it
held true and then one thing you don't
like about us yes please what
about each of us i would love the
transparency i really would all right
uh okay so the one thing that is
actually true like that is perceived and
is actually true graham is so freaking
frugal
okay like i show up and i was telling
him about the
towels and the lights and to me it just
didn't make sense
because i was like okay you make all
this money on youtube
it's more of an investment and i'm not
saying get the fanciest lights you can
i'm not trying to say that
i'm just trying to say get some
diffusers like get some get some you
know
a soft box or or whatever it is um
so that's the one thing you as well you
you don't spend money it's true it's
insane
yeah yeah and you know what jack told me
something he's like
when you work here he's like you don't
have time to spend money
wait a second true i'm gonna take a
quick break
i might have something for you surprise
okay
yeah so this is a gift i want to present
to you it is
uh from eric open it up no no
that's awesome guys so this is from
carrots
i so this is under my account but now
you don't need to ask my permission
if i ask you to go and buy something now
you have a credit card
a business credit card that you could
spend
under me so that so i see what you're
spending on that
uh i pay for it but for any legitimate
business expenses now you have your own
card that you could spend
that congratulations that's amazing do
you
have a gram stuff in business card no a
matter of fact
i don't have a grammy business credit
card no because here's what happened you
went to go and buy a hose
and i asked you to buy and hose from
lowe's or wherever it was
and uh then you gave me the receipt i
had to pay you back i'm like that's
stupid you know what now
i'm going to get you a credit card under
my account and then that way if you
spend anything
i'm paying for it anyway so and open it
up i've seen this card
well kind of no you haven't seen that
one can i see yo this
is thick it's a there's no numbers on
the front
this is a thick boy
it's like gold that's really really
fancy
let me see it wow that's cool i like the
gold
so don't why that's cool that's awesome
why does it have a home on it
uh so carrick customizes the credit card
so you don't need to have
a uh oh so the name oh yeah
so there's the name back there but yeah
on the front you don't need to have
anything on the front so they just put a
house on it talk to the viewers for a
second just just
have a 30 seconds with them i saw so
many great applications
i i'm sure they did too i just want to
say everybody did a really good job
um i've had some really awesome people
who like reached out and and they told
me my video was good before they even
knew i got the job
um so so i appreciate that and i'm sure
you guys will get to
kind of get to know me as i might appear
in some stuff but
um i'll be a lot behind the scenes yeah
and who knows
you might be working with somebody who's
watching this at some point in the
future you probably will be
all right chances are so you got you got
to say
to any future people who might end up
working with us so
anybody who is going to come work for
graham in the future
you know six months a year two years
down the line three years down the line
run man you know well you still can't
unsubscribe like mace
thanks for joining too what do you have
to say yeah
i feel like yeah you got it you got to
speak up
i don't know what to talk about just
shout out savannah smiles on youtube
yeah your amazon affiliate link
is in the description of one of those
videos i've made
have you guys ever wanted to send fan
mail
oh yeah plug the p.o box so if anyone
wants to send stuff to
me or graham i mean usually i unbox it
so you might get my reactions it's not
grams
but i do have a po box it is 9360
west flamingo road suite 110
number 536 las vegas nevada 89147
it's in the description if you want to
send any of us any any fan mail
but you got to put either my name or
macy's name on it you don't put jack or
alex because they're going to be like
who who is this
it's got to be one of our names cool so
with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
as always make sure to destroy the
subscribe button like button and
notification bell also feel free to add
us on instagram
i posted pretty much daily so if you
want to be a part of it there feel free
to add us there
make sure by the way to get your free
stock down below in the description
public is going to be giving you a free
stock worth all the way up to 50
you may as well do that and you get a
chance to earn a tesla stock
uh by april 16th so you gotta do it by
april 16th
and uh enjoy thanks so much for watching
alex thanks so much for coming on
thank you guys join the team and until
next time we have to complete the funnel
guys go subscribe to the vlog channel oh
and this is the family
right do i say my name first yeah
welcome back to the 47th ever episode of
the yes coffee on my name
alex and so far the podcast is made